let's go next to rj from wisconsin
r.j you're on the air hi there did you
hear me i can
hey thank you for taking my call um
i just want to say i you know personally
i'm fairly relieved about the
result of yesterday's trial it seems
that uh upwards of maybe 85 to 88
percent of america is as well
um but i i guess i want to touch on you
know something that's been coming up in
the news
and that's the shooting that occurred in
columbus as well
and all the um protests that are coming
as a result of that
right i watched that video
several times um and you know obviously
nobody knows the
exact details of that yet but i guess my
question to you is
do we need to in some ways draw a line
to
where we're willing to protest some of
these things if
use of force is is is use of force ever
a justifiable
method from law enforcement and
is there a line that we are going to
draw
you know as democrats or as
as liberals that um
we we would be willing to accept any
reason for
use of force by a police officer or so
are you are you saying are there any
circumstances where it's okay for police
to use deadly force is that your
question
well yeah i guess in what circumstance
would that be okay i mean it looked to
me
from the video and i'm again i'm just
going off of what i've seen in slow
motion by less but
you know it looked like the one
individual had had possibly a knife or
something like that that was going after
another individual
well listen i haven't i haven't seen
this specific video
but certainly there are of course there
are situations where
police use of force up to deadly force
is is warranted
uh what we want is for uh
as a society to have a really good
feeling
that police are good at determining when
that's appropriate and you can go
through all sorts of different scenarios
and active gunmen
uh and police show up certain hostage
situations
someone who's about to set off a bomb i
mean the the
i i recognize and accept the the
legal framework in which police are able
to use
up to deadly force but i think that the
debate i've not heard
any liber i mean okay i guess there's
some people who don't want police at all
and maybe they would say police
shouldn't ever even
fire a gun no matter what far left
99 of everybody a hundred percent of
everyone i've personally spoken to
uh understands that sometimes police use
deadly force and it's a is appropriate
right and i guess i guess my question is
is is
you know there are clear instances where
obviously
you know police intervention need you
know and use of deadly force
is necessary yes but you know given that
you know i guess in terms of of
going forward with protests and things
like that if we're
you know are we willing to on our side
acknowledge the fact that maybe
there is you know it say in that
situation if they had you know if the
individual did have a knife and was
going after
after the other individual you know are
we willing to accept that yes because
that was an african-american that was
that was you know unfortunately shot by
by a white police officer
that were willing to admit that you know
that was that was a justifiable use of
of force in that instance listen you'd
have to ask
people who i guess are on some other
side of this
my my view is that just the race of the
of an officer and the race of the person
that gets shot
doesn't tell you whether the actions of
the officer were acceptable that's my
position you know
you're getting into a lot of other other
things that don't really
reflect my views so i would maybe talk
to people who are more of that of that
mindset i appreciate the phone call very
much and it's an important question
um but i think that it's also important
not to
i mean police should never use force
period is not one i've really heard
so i'm not inclined to spend too much
time arguing about it because it seems
99.9 percent of the country is
is on the same page on that okay i'm up
i apologize i wasn't able to
pick up more phone calls i did what i
could we will take a break and we will
take calls again